This is Alex Kelly and I am sitting here with Noeliz Luisa Lee
Luisa Lee and it is January twenty-first two thousand
fifteen. We're sitting here at City College at the accessibility center and
I am interviewing Noeliz for Andrew's High School Braile and
Talking Book Library's project 'Invisible Lives Oral Histories of the Disability
Experience' through the New York Public Library. I'm just going to start out
Noeliz and ask you a little bit about where you came from. You can tell me a little bit about your background. OK,
Ok, well I come from the Bronx, New York.
That's where I was born and raised, um, I like to think that I come from two different
places. My ethnicity is Chinese and Dominican, so I'm both Asian and
Hispanic. And my father is Chinese and my mother is Dominican so I like to
think that I was imported and that I was born here.
Well right now I'm twenty-two. And I'm going to school and I'm studying
environmental engineering at the City College of New York. And I
just got approved to graduate so I'm super excited about that, I'm gonna to finish, thankfully.
And, you know, I came to this project because I'm
a student registered here at the disability center and at first it was hard for
me to register myself here because most students don't really know
about other students disabilities. They usually try to keep it, you know, not as well
known or they tell their closest friends. But once I registered myself here
I found a whole new community of students that are just like me and they made
me feel welcomed and my grades drastically improved once I started
coming here, registered with the center, and really, like, made a
community and made my home here. I'm currently the secretary for the
disability club that we have here at City College. And I've been involved in a lot of
disability awareness projects. And, in my view, what
the accessibility center tries to do is, not only educate the public about different
types of disabilities but also aid students that have these disabilities and
communicate with these students as well as the professors or try to communicate
through their peers.
Great.  Seems like a really amazing place. You know I can tell as soon as I walked through the door.
Tell me what- I want to go back a little bit.
Tell me a little bit about growing up in the Bronx, and kind of early childhood memories
Well, growing up in the Bronx is tough.
It really, you know, makes you a New Yorker when you grow up in the Bronx.
My parents immigrated here. So they went through the immigrant
experience. My mom worked in a factory job and my dad used to work in
Philadelphia also on a factory job, and what ended up happening is that my
father, um, ended up actually going back to college with my older sister
So they ended up graduating together I believe in 2001. So that really inspired
me, you know to keep on going and my mom also ended up going back to college and my
dad finished his two degrees by the time I think he was forty and he
had three kids already. So I think that was a big source of inspiration especially you know
coming from the Bronx and the type of economical
social situation that you're in.  For them to persevere, come from another country, and learn the
language and, you know, end up getting their degrees that was something really
motivational for me and it keeps me going 'til today,  'til I see my
dad at work wake up every morning and go to work, and just realize
that he provided for my family, as well as my mom. She also
provided and worked a factory job to just try to maintain the household.
I think that's a big motivational thing for me and
I think that's something that the Bronx really does them for . These are working class people
that really built up for themselves, a community that's really strong and
they try to send their kids to college and they try to really make sure that their kids get
a proper education and I think that's what my parents did and they did a good job. I'm graduating, so
I'm really excited.[Congratulations.] Thank you. [So this is your last semester?]
I got approved to graduate the next Fall.
[OK.] And then I walk the next spring. So right now I'm working on
a project - a geology project, which is, um, to actually go to a
Third World country and try to create a engineering
system which the local people can run which actually filters out
the unclean, unpotable water and makes it clean water so that way they can eat,
they can bathe, and they can run it themselves and it'll be something
that is economically sound for them to run as well as a very viable
plan for a Third World country to have because you know, as we know, some of these countries
water is a precious resource and, um, these people get sick from
drinking unpotable water, and that's the type of work that I want to
do, that's a type of work that I wanna hopefully accomplish with a
non-profit in the future, if I get to work with one. [That sounds amazing.]
OK you're kind of making me want to do it.
Thanks. The inspiration came from my parents, since they came
from the Dominican Republic. And right now they have a
sort of great economical resources in terms of speaking as a Third World country, they are not considered to
be one. But I remember that they told me that when they were younger,
They had to go to a stream to wash their clothes and get water in.
so that way they can go to their houses and they didn't have the amenities that we do have
now. And so seeing how they grow up and hearing stories about them
and what they needed to do to just get clean water sort of inspired me to
get into a field where I can make a difference in someone's life.  Even though I'm not there
physically, I'm still there trying to start a project to
hopefully touch someone else's life, maybe someone I've never even met, and try to get them
a basic resource which is water.  Water, you know, is what we need to
keep ourselves healthy and I think that making a viable
resource for them to reach that water is something that we as a country
in the United States, we need to do for other countries. Help them to develop a system
where they can get their people - first it's water then we can go in with something like
education. But it all starts with a basic resource and then building upon it.
Mm
It's amazing.  And so your parents seem like incredible people, I just wanna
kind of go back a little bit.  What types of stories that they share with you about work?  What
types of, kind of words of wisdom did they pass on to you growing up?
And, did you have siblings?  Oh, yes I do.  I have two siblings.  I have an older
sister and I have a younger sister. And I remember like one story that my
dad told me. And it was when we were building my backyard
actually.  We recently bought a house and this was when I was about twelve or thirteen
and it was a big deal for us and my backyard was just full of dirt
and mud and grass and, um, he told me, you know, we're going to build
paradise. I really didn't understand what that meant I was just like, dad, you're just gonna
make a garden in the backyard. I didn't understand that. So then me and him we started
doing the backyard work together and he taught me how to, you
know, pick up the weeds and clean the backyard and we eventually made
the backyard out of tiles. He taught me how to put in the tiles and it was such
hard work to do it with him, and it was a family project. But in the end of the
project I actually understood what he was talking about. He meant we're going to build paradise
in the United States.  The backyard was going to be my parents', like, safe haven where they
can garden and things like that and my mom ended up growing
sunflower plants, like, on the back wall and my dad ended up
making like his own little corner with his chair where he can listen to his like sixties
music which, you know, he showed me pictures of him in an afro
so that was funny enough.
But I understood the, the whole process you know.  I work hard with them to build
something that the whole family can enjoy and each little
piece, like my mom's flower garden and my dad's, my dad planted an apple tree and a pear
tree and they just started giving fruit, you know, within a couple of
years.  That was a big deal for us and it meant, you know
we've reached a point in our lives that we can now enjoy
the fruits of our labor, it's - we worked hard to get there but now that we got there
let's work even harder to make sure that we can create a place that we can all share
and I think that was what really clicked with me with the sense of community and
we ended up creating a community garden and people come from, you know, next door because
the gardens have passageways through all the houses and everyone sort of created their own little
niche and we visit each other all the time and cook outside and I think it's even
cute when I'm - like, little squirrels and little animals come to my garden and steal things.
So I, I think that even the sense of community, even having like a squirrel come in to take
an apple from a tree. It's something very small but you know it's something
very enriching I think for me to grow up, enriching to
know that hard work pays off. And when it does pay off
you have to get back to everyone else.
I think that's the biggest lesson.  That's great.  That's amazing. So great that you
have that space too that you share with your family that you all work together to
build. So tell me a little bit about your decision to go to
City College and what that was like, and, you know, a little bit about your
history and education kind of growing up in the school system.
Well I went to CEX eleven. That's a public school in the Bronx.  It was very
close to my house and, um, I just remember going to school every day my
mom would dress me up in pig-tails and I would hate it and I
just grew up a very normal life.  And then I went to a private school
Sacred Heart Middle School and that's a private institution.  It's a Catholic
school.  And I went there because it was also close to my
house and by that time, nine-eleven already happened. So my parents wanted me
to stay closer to the house, closer to the home, and they made a big sacrifice to send me to a
private school. But they know that it was, you know, more in the interest of safety to keep me
closer to the house.  And my dad is actually an educator in Washington
Heights and he's been there for over twenty-something years so for him, our
safety was important and getting home was important after nine-eleven. And my
high school experience, I went to Mother Cabrini High School.  And I remember distinctly
in my junior year that I went to a counselor in an outside of school
program and I told that counselor that- about my disability and they
said, you know, I don't think that you're going to make it through high school.
And I said, you think I'm NOT gonna make it through high school?
And then I took a course I was really upset and I told my
parents. So then I went in the next year and I ended up
graduating valedictorian top of my class and I went back to him
. And I showed him that I graduated top of my class and I got accepted into
N.Y.U. in college and I got accepted into all these great
colleges that have all the programs that I wanted to attend and he just
said you know good job and I'm so old so you said to me good job when you figure it
out but I had a disability and told me I couldn't do it.
So when I went back there and you know I showed him what I did and I was like
. What I really need to do this. No need to show you anything.
You're someone that doesn't know what they're talking about. You can sit there you call
yourself a counselor for a program the children's you know kids attend after
school and you tell someone they can't do something
. I really told my parents and they went with me and
they spoke to the gentleman and apparently he wasn't very well versed
in how to speak to students that have disabilities. He thought that he could just say you know
you're not going to make it so I'm going to make it. Why. Because if we're going to have a
disability or you know because I come from the Bronx or
my you know racially profile to be successful in going to
college what are you really telling me I think that was a big motivator in my life I was
in something huge in my life where out while other people that exist like him
because with my disability my parents didn't really. Single me out. They may need
the same as everybody else. I've always lived in a place where I was the same as everybody
else. I didn't really talk about a disability unless you know people asked. And when
I told them that I educated them they understood about it but this was one person
that was educated clearly went to college has a degree in counseling
and didn't know what to tell me. Besides you never made it to college
. That was a big motivator for me and it still is today.
And when I got my college degree I would go back to his office and I want to be like well
I finally got over it and I think just having
that strength and speaking to people and at a young age I was I was speaking to him like if I
was an adult like seventeen or sixteen when I met him and he told
me you know we're going to make it and I went to him by myself. And I told him
Listen I am going to make it I'll come back to you because you know I'm tough
. I'm suffering from the Bronx.
You know you can get the bronze up the girl but you can get the girl of the Bronx
and I think.
With my education that's something that really motivated me and even now in
college I ran through an experience where I had to tell a professor that he asked me in
public. To me my disability. And that was a
really embarrassing experience I went to the senator
.
And I told them about it. And they were really happy to
. Sort of name my experience where my disability if you have people have
never met me. And the cells are they counseled
me and they brought me back up. And they told me about my rights as a disabled
student. And I was able to go to that professor. I
was able to tell him you know my rights were violated. He had no idea
. And it was a very traumatic experience to go through
because I would never have someone call me out in public and tell me
you know we should you should tell me what your disability is because
if you don't I'm not going to accommodate you.
And that was something that I went through and I came to the center here
and I talked to a counselor. And they helped me through it and I
eventually finished the class easing it and I
went back to this professor and I said you never knew I had a disability and I was going to show you days in
your class. And once you know I had a disability. You told
me to name it in front of everybody else. And I refused to do so
. And I told him it was illegal for him to ask me.
And once he knew that I was knowledgeable about exactly what was being asked of me
. He immediately stopped. And I
gave him a pamphlet on the disability center. And I felt
like that's how he. Ended up being educated. And then he
explained to me that he came from a different country or people that have disabilities are not
considered the same as he was. He apologized to me
because he told me I would never be an engineer. He told me that I would change my
major and that I should pick something else because no one would want to work with me because of my
disability. When he
apologized to me. And I took it in and I was
. Sort O. grateful. For the fact that he
eventually learned from living in the cloud of ignorance where he thinks that
people with disabilities shouldn't have the same opportunities as everybody else
. And I eventually ended up having a good relationship with this professor
. But it reminds me that people at this. Level. Oh
college. I actually believe that students with disabilities can
make it. And once I finish classes it's this class and
. I went to the to the next couple of classes. I just
took what he's told me and they said all this is this is got to change.
We have to educate people and that's when I became secretary of the club
. And I became a lot more active as a student to voice
. The fact that students with disabilities are not what people think they are. They look
like everyone else if their disability is really apparent and
that students with disabilities can do everything that other students can do. And that's
when I became more involved in the community here and. Through my life
learning and being educated in these were a couple of select
people that told me you can't do it you can't make it. You should find
something else to do because you will never get there and I'm still here
and I'm Brazilian and I am proof that. I can make it and if I
can do it everyone else can.
So it seems like you are teaching people a lot
. I just with two gentleman you know who
.
Who were obviously coming from a place of sense you
know I just I respect so much that you came back to that means that
doesn't make this Israelis are my rights and I'm sure that a lot of
people listening to this story. Villains. Do you want to
talk a little bit about your disability. Yeah like that was like over the years
. Well I was diagnosed of having A.D.T.
.
And at first you know my parents didn't really believe it because they came from a country
where things like that don't exist.
OK so they didn't believe in it and then my dad
he's actually had a teacher. And he is an engineer by profession with a
degree and he actually started reading up more about it he was like you know what
I think you're right we should look into this and then my mom she
also ended up looking into it was my dad. If you
mention he went to a doctor and I was diagnosed I.V. and then
when they started researching more and then they research with me I was about ten. That's when
we started learning more about it and then we start learning that there are a lot of kids that are like me
and then we also started learning about people that don't think it's real. So they think it's something that
people make up and my response to that
. Is that my parents stood with me and they still stand by with me
and they believe that everything that I'm doing is correct to educate people why it's easy
since there are so many people who believe that it doesn't exist and as a student trying to study with
A.D.D. it's really hard it's not that you don't want to study Islam or you're not
motivated to study or anything it's just. There's there's
something sort of with every age it is to for everybody but for me it's
something where I'm reading a paragraph.
And I know that I'm reading it I know that I'm reading it word for word but am I really understanding it.
So there's a difference between reading it understanding the concept building on the concept
and then applying the concept which is something that's really important for a student like me to
get. So I eventually grew up with my dad sort of teaching me as long as my
mom and they read with me every single day so then they sat down with me like
so you read it do you understand it. Did you grab the main point. So now how do you apply
it.
But I guess that's why I decided to do so much in engineering.
It really is about reading the constant understanding the concept of applying the
concept but how can you make it go further in your studies with math and science
. So with my project of course it's a lot of reading involved a lot of
engineering projects that I have to look up to build upon them to then apply
what I do learn and then making something positive come out of it.
And I think that's one of the major big influences that I have in
education my parents. They sat by with me. They you know
sat down with me learning to read and learning to grasp concepts
and they're some of the you know biggest motivators for me and
sit behind me every single time that I go to take a test or an exam
and they even built a desk for me to study in my house and things like
that. Even though last night I was taking my classes and my
parents because they didn't want me to get home late at night because it was so cold. They would
actually drive and wait for me outside of school. So I finished and then they
would pick me up and take me home. You know there's a lot of parents do that at this age
that I'm an adult but they didn't do it for me because they understand that engineering is a very
hard discipline. And I like to call it a discipline because it's not something that you study
it's something that you have to be very dedicated to and discipline yourself
to not only study work the professor selling you but take the concept
go further and you have to read a lot.
Just to understand something and use it and apply it. And I
think.
That that's how my parents really eating me with
my own learning disability and I think that I
think parents that have children that A.T.T. should also help their kids like
that they should sit down with their kids and you know explain to so many kids are
young so they don't really understand what it is explain to them this is what you have and educate their own
kids so they can educate other people correctly.
For people who say it doesn't exist. Can you share a
story or a moment that kind of illustrates that. Yes it does and this is what it feels
like.
Well I think one of the moments that I can really paint a picture of
is I was studying for class last semester
and I don't really do very well in my math classes and I
think that's why I like math there's not a lot of reading in it there's just you know apply concepts do.
But this class was more based on theory. So I had to read a lot more
applying the concept and do and one of the problems that I had in this math
class was that it didn't matter how many times that I've read the book over
. It didn't matter how many times that I would watch problems I knew too
it was really hard to understand what was a next step or what
is the concept that I'm missing that I need to apply some sort of
. Mathematical augmentation to the problem so I can get the
desired answer.
And I would sit there for hours and engineers you know as
usual they study for days on end to try to aim for final so it was normal
for me to study maybe three days on and taking breaks and going back to my room and locking
myself in and studying and I eventually started I created a
whiteboard in my room so I just took transparency paper and taped it up and my parents thought
that I was running the wall so I made my own little white board and
I went to get markers and I started doing every single problem in the book
until I saw a pattern until I saw something that I could understand.
And this took me a while to do. And every time that I would see a
pattern I would write it down every time that I would see something that I didn't understand I would have to
go back and recheck and recheck.
So people are saying that it doesn't exist it does exist I would not
spend all these hours studying something.
Now I understand the concept when my friend who doesn't have a disability understood it right away
. There's no difference between me and my friend we're the same age we study the same
thing. We you know G.P.A. wise were the same the only
difference is that. I think a little bit longer to understand a concept and she doesn't
. I think a little bit longer to something to really sink in
. But that doesn't make me any different from her at all.
And with when I did my process of learning and taping things to the
wall and researching. All their math books I said last books from
my dad and he went to school you know the dinosaur each basically
took his books and his books like Spanish and I started reading it in Spanish.
Anderson a lot more in Spanish than I did in English and my first language is English.
But you know growing up in a mixed language household I got a hold of both of the
languages and their reading material in another language and I understood a
lot better. And I thought that was really you know interesting and funny because
there's people that wrote the two different languages and studying in the U.S.
and the only reading textbooks in English and I was like it's a shame that there are not
a lot of textbooks in Spanish even now my dad was telling me he's an eighth
grade teacher now and he teaches in high school and there's a lot of students that speak
Spanish and come from a country that they've only been taught Spanish and he works hours
on end translating material in mathematics from English or Spanish
and he said you know I do it because these kids don't know what they don't know
. And we have to teach them. And the only way to do that is to take
material translating it. And that's the only way they're going to understand the
concept and apply the concept. And he spends hours and hours doing
that. And I spent hours and hours reading an English book and I understood the
material in Spanish and I didn't know that until I started taking my dad's books and started
reading it and.
I think. That part of education especially in
a city that's as diverse as New York is something else all
affected me where I would read things in English and didn't really
understand them or to listen to reading them in another language.
So interesting studies that are done and they're you know they should
have been. So usually both the moving of your
diagnosis. Like maybe there were moments leading up to it
like wonder like you know what.
Well I knew there was something wrong with me I was always like a very smart kid. So
I would research the internet on the newest style for like I would see something on the news
that there was talk about some virus I would research myself and my parents when I
was ten and they were very computer savvy so I was and I said I
was looking at stuff by myself and I was like I feel different I feel different to everybody else I
don't understand things as fast as the other kids do like when they're the
problem where they're answering questions they get it faster and I decided that they were
something I didn't click with me. And having parents that came from another country where
some of the stuff doesn't even really exist or reporting in these and their
country. I started doing research for myself so naturally I went to the library
. The public library where a lot of information and I
use a computer there and I was figuring out you know that I feel sort
of sluggish or slow or that I didn't understand the concept as fast as
everybody else and then I started reading up about it and then there are kids that
have blogs or their parents read the blogs sort of talking about it. So once I showed
it to my parents my parents they were like No you have you.
Know these are all the other kids have that.
And then when my dad and my mom started looking up more into it they were like OK so
I think we should go to a doctor to see if this is something that
she might have. And we ended up you know going at ten
and then a little bit later as I grew up as an adult and then they
came to not only understand except. Act
on what I have. But also. Be a proactive
part of my life.
And I think that that's what you know if there is their kids or parents are recently finding out that their child has
that you research accepting it act on it and be proactive about it
.
But students at the college are really interested in your experience here and
what it was like to come to the accessibility Center for the first time and what kind of brought me
here and with that back on that teacher in class to be part of it is there anything else that
kind of made you feel like OK.
Also because I think they're more accepting curious
then you know people that probably have never heard about it in their entire life
they were expecting they're more curious.
They asked me questions like you know can you read this or are you OK with that
.
Our own classes where I sit next to a friend of mine and she's been in class with me I think
twice and she understands that sometimes I can't read what's on the board or
sometimes it looks like I have double vision for me and I see it too. Of
one thing written on the board or some letters to me just don't
click with me. So she'll sit down with me and she'll write big enough so I can see her notebook
or she'll make me a copy of her book and highlight things that she thinks are important for me.
And I think that's a community that you have a city college that students are willing to do that for their fellow
students. They're willing to learn a lot more and they're more accepting and curious
if anything and they're willing to help you and say you know can you read this
so you understand this do you want to go over this problem and I think that one of my
friends Her name is Catherine and she helped me and one of my math classes and we both ended up
getting A's on it and I told her I'm like I think you're the reason I got an A because he really
helped me and she you know we sat down together and studied together like no tomorrow
and I think that's a type of community that we have among our peers at City College
as what sort of inspired me to go to the accessibility center it wasn't
only the comment from that teacher I think it was more of I kept meeting students
that were more more like me. And you would never know they hate you because they look like everybody
else. Until he told you. And when I met them
and we started talking about the same experiences like the experience of not understanding
hours and hours of reading something just to understand one concept like
this is really this is you know friends that I've been to see my entire
life and I've always had normal friends so I felt more at home with them
and they were very welcoming when I first came here and I just come in here like a
regular day and I just you know chill or talk to everybody about
classes or get help in some class and I'm having trouble with and I
think that's a community that they try to make it possible and I think they make you feel safe.
What is it like connecting with other students who are diamonds. Do
you have interesting conversations or points of connection is this like one of the first
cases for people to do that
. Yeah well I met one of my friends Her name is Holmes and she also
has a team and when we sat down to talk to each other we
were talking about you know. What did we go through having a needy and one of the
biggest things was you know people don't believe it exists.
So I was like one of the major points people who believe this is this they don't know what we're feeling until you
really have to have a do you know what it's like and I was like one of our biggest
sort of conversations and when I sat down with her and
she told me about her experience of she's reading.
And it takes a lot for her to read and I am reading and it takes a lot for me to read and to
understand and she was telling me you know the trouble that she has taking
exams as well because she feels a pressure like all the other students are finishing the exam
and she's not finishing on time and that happens to me and you know I was telling
her like as an engineering student some other problem solving takes so long pages of it is
they don't want to answer. But that sometimes takes me longer to figure out
. What is the next step in the problem. And what I'm allowed
to do as a student that's registered here is take my
exam here in the center and take it in a quiet place
and they give me extra time to sort of collect my thoughts and figure
it out and I feel like that's been a bigger factor for students
here that they get the chance to sit down and think about the excess of what
they're supposed to be doing and I think that when I've met her
and she sort of told me about the center and told me about the
experiences students have here and about the exam experience is terrifying
because I mean that's that's what college is based on exams and getting good grades and things
like that which she told me about that I was like oh my god like where was this
my entire life because I've been taking exams with normal students and I
haven't been able to finish just because I haven't been able to read
correctly understand the concept and I've been fortunate that I found a lot of teachers to actually
take time. Out of their regularly scheduled day and they will sit down with
me and tell me you know this is what I want you to do or this is why I can better help
you. And I thought it was not a very proactive in trying to learn about students like
me how to better teach them instantly.
So it's a really exciting time to be here. You are graduating next
file and you're thinking about this project
.
Well right now the location is chosen as Bangladesh. OK so I'm really excited
about that and it was not another friend of mine and when
I spoke to her she said she read about it in the semester and I talked to her and she talked to
me about her project and I ended up applying for just to get
research at the school and I ended up meeting someone that's in
charge of her project and of course this person didn't know that we were friends until I mentioned oh my
God I'm friends with her and they were like so you can take over her project when she graduates
. You can be a continuation of her project. Every project was based on water
resources and she may need an entire research project about water resources in
Bangladesh and I wanted my project to be a continuation of her since she is
my friend and I would love her country and I love her culture so
much different from mine and she taught me so much about her country in
Bangladesh and now you know the struggle that people go through there on a regular
basis and I will say I think it'll be interesting to bring my fusion
of being Hispanic and Asian and bringing her fusion and
I'm like well you know might as well be. You know a citizen of your country
and I think. That when we develop that community of I'm from here you're from
there. Well let's meet somewhere in the middle. That's when I started thinking about
what is it that she needs for me to do. Because if you know it was part of her
plan to develop this water system and then now my plan is
how can I make it work. And I think if I can get more like minded people think how
can I make it work.
You know whether it be an engineering project or anything like that I think it's a more productive use of
time. So I saw her project and said OK so you're
graduating How can I make your project and make it real. Make it tangible make
it something that. These people can run for themselves. And
don't lead don't need to rely on anyone These are people that live in small village communities that can have a
system or they can clean their own water and filter their own water and hot water
to cook to clean to do basic necessities. And you
sort of make these people. The same as other people that are fortunate enough to have clean water
.
And I think the can do attitude that she has and then I have sort of
melded together and we're like let's make this a melting pot. Let's go. But you know
Tino's and put the faucet together let's put the whole of the U.S. but everything together in the
pot and make one big dinner and I think that's one of the most
positive things that I found about my friends here City College to come from everywhere around the
world get to learn about so many different communities in so many different cultures
and I think that was a big motivator for me in this project.
And so I'm just thinking with a major project to grow water it's like something that
everybody regardless of your background or income from
it all comes down to this like basic necessity
. So after you
graduate What are your hopes for the future. What are your thoughts. You know
where you're going to next.
Well after I graduate and I finished the internship program that I'm with
I was offered a graduate program position in
engineering. Hopefully I get to do that but I was also thinking
about either going to law school. Or business school
so you know we had a couple friends are going together or something for the G.R. he sent hopefully we'll get
some we get some more of that.
But I think that home. Life. My biggest goal is to help people
. So you know it's not necessary to be a doctor.
I think another way to help people is that what I'm doing and hopefully I want to work
with the U.N.. And with the
. U.N. portion that works with communicating to
countries and getting them aid and was a project like mine I want to get
to an engineer position. Where I can work with the World Bank and I know
that they fund projects that help countries that
are in dire need of you know water resources and working as an
engineer with them. I can hopefully help. Pass you know
legislation or funding for these countries that really need
these types of engineering systems. So their population can get basic
needs of just water. And like you said water is something over a unifying
motif. And I want to get to a position where I can help these
people. Maybe I'm not going to be right there next to them are traveling to that country
but you know from my country I can sort of lend a helping hand to their
country. And I think that's a lot more unifying and a lot more
humanitarian.
It's great. It's very exciting for him
. Is there anything you want to talk about right now in this thing you
know I. Think. We haven't been able to talk about. It's important for other people to know
about you in your life. I mean listen to this years
.
I think that. I think the biggest message I want to get out here is not
the disability part. It's the biggest message is
.
If you're here and you're doing something
. And you're doing something that
. You know is life changing for you try to change someone else's
life not your own.
I think that's like a big message because what I'm trying to do is not only because
you know I want to have a job like everybody. Oh I don't know
because you know I want to have a job a house you know a dog named Sparky in
the future I don't know but what I'm what I'm trying to do is.
I like to use the word humanitarian a lot. I'm trying to look at the bigger picture. I'm not you know one
person of course you know I want the job with the solvent to
graduate you know. And. But the bigger picture
here is with this oral history is to communicate that.
We should be doing more not just resting on laurels not just saying well
you know the Red Cross can do this and do that or whatever you know I'm not going to
be you know Mrs save the world and be so a woman in charge at home
everyone else but if you're doing something even though it's a little like opening the door.
That's something that's changed someone else's life I like to think that we all live in our own little bubbles
of course even when we're on the train New Yorkers are nasty to each other they ignore each other
they just go on you know through the train through life and don't really look at the
person sitting next to them or standing next to you know how is this person's day
even when you bump into someone you'll get the response. Watch out. I move
over and I think if you take a minute of your day to realize that you know we all
live in different spaces and we all live in our own little bubble spoke when our bubbles interact with each other
with a simple touch we do impact each other. So you know I live in my
own little mobile right now in New York in the Bronx or whatever but what an adventure really hoping to do is
that when I graduate I get to be part of these projects that touch other people's
life bubbles. In other countries who have never met but I am doing
something to help them and that's a way of touching someone else. So I think the
simple message of just touching someone else touching their lives and
you don't even have to know who they are but working to change something to
make someone else's life better I think is a much better use of my time and I to use the
word proactive a lot so I try to stay proactive and I think that is a productive
use of time. So you know since we're here on this earth we're not just you know one
person living one life in League One little bubble trying to make sure that we all
interact with each other. And really go on to something more
progressive than what we're living right now. Because at the end of the day you know when we grow
older we have kids and we have to leave the world a better place than what it was before
because if we haven't done that then we've not progressed people at all and I
think that's what we need to start doing now. And with
. Last night the president's State of the Union address he was talking about you know in a
couple months we're going to go to Mars. I'm so excited that I got to live
through that I got to you know I'm living through having a
African-American president.
I'm living through you know hopefully maybe seeing Hillary in the White House. These are
life changing things that I'm living through and living through people getting to
Mars.
This is a progressive use of our time of exploring what's out there and
also progressive use of science and technology to try to make people's lives better
and I think that's what we need to move out of people.
It's great I think it's a beautiful when it's all just. Individuals starting
out a small internet you anything you put that together is
going. Well I really want to
thank you for sharing your story and spend and spend inspiring for me. My voice
is a little worse for me to listen to you and I'm sure that it will inspire
others and. I. Do you know
anything else that you want to say any questions anything. Anything else that you want to make
sure is on the record before I pressed on
.
I just hope whoever is like listen to this like really takes it into
themselves and. Sort of looks at how can I change the world
in my own little place in my own little niche in my own little community and I think that's.
The last thing I want to say. Great wonderful. So you
know as you brought up an object here today can you tell me a little bit about it and why
they brought it.
Well I bought a pair of my old glasses and I brought them because
I think. The fact I mean. My glasses are the ones I've actually seen everything
that I go through as a student with A.D.D. they actually you know I wear them on my face
and. Besides me seeing the world as I do they see
the world as I do so I think hopefully with the picture that you're going to take of my
glasses someone can see the world like I do. I thought you know it's sort of
a quirky thing to print because not everybody wears glasses but since we're
all different and like glasses are different on everybody else everyone has a different pair.
Mike there is how I see the world. Hopefully my option is
inspirational enough for people to wake up and grab their own pair of glasses
and realize you know we all see the world differently but it's one world. It's
one vision that we have. So let's make the vision greater and brighter
and more progressive. And I think that's why I brought my glasses because
besides me living what I have been living through my glasses have also been there with me
seeing what I lived through those glasses can talk
I know they can talk they're probably you know going to say I've
been broken a couple of times.
She doesn't take care of me at all.
Oh you know they're a little bit broken a little bit on even and you know
on the sides of them we have a little sparkly. I'm very girly
but. I think if they can say something they would
really talk about the struggle that I went through or the struggle I'm going through
now. Now does a city with a disability but just as a person as a whole
. Everyone has their own you know different type of struggle. But I
. Think if they could speak they would probably do a better job of
telling my story than I would if it would be you know as a third person perspective
I mean B. C. you know what does she do on a regular day.
And I think. That seeing my vision
. And seeing the vision that I do have. And
you know bringing these glasses and you. Can sort of help other people
. And sort of give them the correct information which is what glasses are supposed to
do anyways.